Alright guys, so here's another example you can see we got the A move we got the B move and then we got the C move right here
So let me draw this out
We take out the high of the A move and then we take out the low of the B move
Right once we do that we reclaim that level and then we enter on the retest
Put the stop those right below the slow and we target one to two that is it
So I hope this is clear to you
This is a very simple trading strategy. So basically, this is liquidy purge liquidy purge and then moving in the
The direction the price is intended to move like
Originally so after taking out the liquidy from the both sides price gonna move to the
Direction it would want to go. So this is how you enter these trades
So guys this is eight for this course. I will be uploading more videos in the future. I'll be adding more content
to this course in the future. So I
Really do hope that you learned something from the scores and I can't guarantee you if you back test these strategies and
Within three to four months you're gonna be insanely profitable
Okay, and I'm sure you're gonna pass your first ever
Pro from challenge
So thank you so much guys for purchasing this course. I really appreciate each and every one of you who trusted me and
We will meet again
In my future videos. So thank you so much and goodbye